[Music]
Rane world effectively illustrates the
cruel indifference of nature as a half
rabbit half slug creature trying to
reunite with its family
you start smack-dab in an unfamiliar
land with an ecosystem where you're both
predator and prey rain is a threat to
your survival but it pales in comparison
to the game's many hunters and
unfortunately unforgiving environments
rain is to blame for the rabbit slugs
isolation to begin with as the opening
cutscene illustrates the storms are what
separated the poor creature from its
family the resulting quest to reunite
with its loved ones is an arduous 2d
trek that challenges you with limited
resources and abilities your most useful
skills are the ones you start with
namely a good throwing arm and a long
jump and if you get caught in the rain
you die the only way you can survive is
if you manage to reach one of the game's
many waterproof shelters reaching a
shelter however you're forced into
hibernation and surviving the long sleep
requires consuming a minimum of four
food items be it flies or fruit a
screams worth of fruit or flies often
provides the food you need but it takes
a few hibernation periods to replenish
as a result you're often compelled to
explore beyond your comfort zone for
other food sources
you can commit a Regents layout and
myriad paths to memory but you're still
vulnerable to many merciless predators
their locations on the map change every
time you emerge from slumber this
typically sustains a moderate level of
freshness in every play session though
it's not uncommon to find yourself in
punishing situations some creatures like
the giant vultures appear with little to
no warning and if your timing is unlucky
a vicious lizard can be waiting for you
at the edge of the next screen in a game
that forces you to mentally juggle
numerous variables to survive these
unpreventable deaths can be exceedingly
frustrating if you do manage to create
distance between you and a lizard the
ensuing chase can be hampered by
platforming issues brain world's
tutorial offers minimal instruction and
learning how to interact with the
environment can be vexing a seemingly
simple act like jumping off a bridge to
grab a metal rod jutting from the
concrete should be easy instead you're
forced to move with the finesse of a
trapeze artist the feeling of which is
at odds with the urgency of escaping a
pursuer you have no chance of defeating
for progress is impedance between each
region passing those gates requires
maintaining a positive win-loss record
in other words your hibernation
frequency has to be higher than your
death rate a seemingly bizarre an
arbitrary requirement having to forage
and hibernate for the sole purpose of
passing a gate feels disrespectful of
the players time since there are no
other rewards for killing and eating as
a result there's a heightened sense of
relief in reaching a new region as you
explore each new area you're hit with a
renewed feeling of resignation and the
acceptance of the many deaths you'll
soon rack up as you reach dead ends and
try to figure out the mainline path to
the next game in an unfair process of
trial and error you make leaps of faith
off cliffs to test whether falling
beyond the bottom of the screen means
your death or the discovery of a new
area
one of the tragedies of reign world
shortcomings is that you don't need to
dig deep to see glimmers of excellence
there are a handful of satisfying
moments of exercising ingenuity when
you're using your environment and
limited resources to your advantage
rain world shines during the rare
moments that encourage improvisation
like when you grab and haul a glowing
Mouse like creature against its will so
you can use its body to illuminate an
otherwise pitch-black area in rain world
the specter of failure often caused by
events you can't control lingers heavily
it's stunningly detailed backgrounds and
few rewarding gameplay opportunities are
vastly outweighed by its platforming and
perfections and hibernation mechanic
which makes little sense in its
connection to accessing new areas
oftentimes the frustrations resulting
from failure devolve and apathy which is
a wholly unfortunate outcome for a game
that gives off a deceptively promising
first impression
[Music]
you